[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes broadcast by spectator TV on
this Thursday the 9th of March my name
is Freddie gray and I will be your host
today
on the show this week we'll look first
to America where the Battle of Ron
versus Don is shaping up that's Ron
DeSantis versus Donald Trump their scrap
for the Republican nomination in next
year's presidential election I'll be
joined by Andrew Coburn and Danielle Lee
Thompson next we'll turn to Westminster
and the political news is all about
immigration this week and Zoella bravman
I'll be joined by The Spectators
brilliant political editor Katie balls
and from London we'll go to Sweden and
talk about the very grisly topic of
Swedish Gangland culture and gun crime
I'll be joined by Ann Turnquist to
discuss that
and then we'll talk about cycling uh
there's been a lot of controversy around
cycling this week after the death of a
cyclist who had an altercation with a
pedestrian
The Pedestrian Oriole gray has been
convicted of manslaughter as a result
I will be joined by two Mary's Mary
dejevski one of our contributors and
Mary Wakefield our commissioning Editor
to talk about that
and lastly what's the matter with
corsets the cast of Bridgeton have been
making a bit of a fuss about corsets
that's the item of clothing and whether
they are too painful to wear I'll be
discussing this difficult debate with
Francesca peacock
and before we get going in Earnest I'd
like to remind you that if you like
spectator TV you should subscribe to
spectator TV and you can do that by
clicking the Subscribe button at the
bottom of your screens now and then
don't forget to click the Bell icon at
the top of your screen to make sure you
never ever miss an episode
and while you're at it why don't you
subscribe to The Spectator magazine it
is after all the oldest and greatest
magazine in the world
at the moment we're doing a special
offer for just 12 pounds you can get 12
weeks of the magazine in print and
online
and on top of that we'll throw in a free
20 pound Amazon voucher
just go to
spectator.co.uk forward slash TV offer
to subscribe
let's begin on American politics for the
cover of the magazine this week I've
written a piece about the looming or
emerging battle between Ron DeSantis and
Donald Trump for the Republican
nomination for the presidential election
next year
Donald Trump spoke at CPAC last weekend
where he tried to Rally the conservative
base in his favor and I think it's fair
to say that he's had a good few weeks
politically he's gaining in the polls
and is emerging once more as the
favorite to win the nomination he does
face a significant challenge however in
the form of Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis who has not officially declared
as a presidential candidate but
everybody knows he's running so who is
going to win I'm joined Now by Andrew
Coburn who is Washington editor of
Harper's magazine as well as Daniel Lee
Thompson who is a scholar and strategist
Andrew I'll start with you uh you wrote
what I think is the best piece I've read
about Ron descent it's called swamp
landia in Harper's magazine
um I wonder if you might start by
telling us a little bit about your
understanding of Ron DeSantis and how it
differs from what perhaps we've heard
here in Britain and internationally
well the general sort of take on Rhonda
Santos says
uh put out in the media is that you know
that he's a very ideological sort of
politician and that he you know
campaigns against woke he was so
outraged by Disney's sort of wokous
liberal positions that he went after
them that he uh you know that he's
generalist you know a Plucky fighter in
the culture wars
um and that's been you know that's the
sort of Main
trust the sort of swear point of his uh
of his campaign and I point out that
actually what he is is the most
distinguishing feature of Ron is that
he's a sort of corporate Toady
um that he's been uh ever since well
certainly ever since he started
campaigning for governor in uh in 2018
that you know he's left no stone
unturned or no uh no donor unturned in
order to um you know shake them down for
really enormous sums of money which has
been amazingly successful at I mean
that's he's really peeled away the uh
main sort of big Republican big donor
base
um and he's been very assiduous at that
both in Florida itself with rather I
think unfortunate results for Floridians
but also for the uh you know across the
country where they all all the
billionaires thrilled with his message
certainly got a lot of money behind him
and the fox uh group of Murdoch Empire
also seems to be supporting him quite a
lot
um do you think in recent weeks uh after
the midterms there was a lot of Ron
DeSantis hype the New York Post called
him Ron the future uh
yeah do you think that
um that has faded slightly and recently
certainly the polls suggest Trump is
pulling ahead again among Republican
primary voters do you think as
desantis's campaign comes into contact
with reality it may start to
disintegrate
yes I think so I mean it's been um you
know certainly the Trump
faction have been or Trump Camp have
been
saying so I think with some justice and
accuracy that you know once DeSantis
starts to sort of go across the country
and have to talk to Ordinary People
which he doesn't like doing very much he
doesn't like people I don't think
um
um unless that sort of proper and huge
checks uh that you know that'll you know
people will sense that
um you know those are so curiously I
mean I compared him in the piece to
Richard Nixon and you know that I you
know they're both both politicians who
didn't like very people very much but
had to pretend they did
um but that sort of comes through you
know whereas Trump you know Trump is
sort of is um
uh uh is a
he has this sort of extra sort of
comedic twist to him he uh
he sort of almost laughs at himself
there's always a slightly
tongue-in-cheek sort of uh
um
aspect of trump which I uh I think
people people like and you know can you
imagine Ron DeSantis trying to do a
dress a trump rally you know that sort
of Maga crowd I mean he'd pull you know
he'd be completely wooden so I think um
I'm not surprised that the uh DeSantis
um
auras fading a bit
Danielle uh you wrote a very
entertaining piece
um about The Vibes at CPAC which is the
conservative political action conference
um uh Trump addressed it last week and
for you it fell quite flat despite a lot
of the talk about Trump's success in the
polls and his rallying of the
conservative base in recent weeks
yes um you know the conservative
political action conference has been a
flagship event for conservatism since
1974 and I remember going there in the
years after Trump just got elected and
there was energy in the air there was
that sort of spirit some sort of
transcendent quality that this was
something new he was offering something
different that expanded Beyond just the
usual culture award dribble of the
Republican party and this year uh as I
said in the piece The Vibes were off uh
I described Vibes as something like a
sense of authenticity and shared spirit
and everyone there from the journalist
to the hardcore Maga types to people who
worked uh you know who have spoken at
CPAC for years felt that something was
off I would say that Trump was just
about the only person who had a little
bit of Verve in the room and honestly I
think it was because he still has a bit
of a nationalist populist appeal in his
two-hour address the majority of what he
spoke about was
um you know free trade Fanatics and
anti-military intervention and also just
taking on the establishment that I
counted in my recordings he had about 30
seconds dedicated to uh like transgender
insanity and CRT but that is very
different from DeSantis who is something
of a culture War chat GPT of sorts
do you think uh the reason the
atmosphere was perhaps a little bit flat
is that Trump conservatism or trumpism
uh has failed it seems at the ballot
three times running now in 2018 in the
midterms 2020 in the presidential
election
and 2022 although it didn't exactly fail
but but a lot of high-profile Trump
candidates
um failed do you think there's a sense
that then they're on the losing side now
you know it's really hard when you make
a career as a winner as a as in the
image of luxury and success to confront
the fact that you failed and it's also
really hard to claim Underdog status
when you've been president of the United
States
that only kind of works so long and on
top of that Trump's style his sort of
bombastic
aggressive uh style which works for him
because he's been doing that on
television in the press for 30 years or
more uh when other people try to copy it
his surrogates and those around him it
continues to fall flat and it seems
inauthentic so it doesn't have the Vibes
so to speak and so in some ways by
trying to copy Trump as CPAC has and
failing to capture the authenticity you
kind of fail to capture what is
interesting about Trump which is a more
Transcendent appeal
did you uh speak to the people there at
CPAC about DeSantis he wasn't there
obviously um it probably would have been
pretty stupid for him to go because he
would have lost the straw pole uh which
showed DeSantis with a huge lead among
the CPAC delegates yes I did speak to
them you know it was firmly Trump Maga
territory a lot of Bannon War Room fans
uh mostly whom are older women I found
uh were at CPAC and I spoke to them the
people who were there for the first time
of course were excited about it because
they were with like-minded people but
the folks who were Veterans of CPAC who
have been there for years who know what
it was like in 2017 or 2018 or even
before that in the Tea Party days uh
they felt something was flat there just
simply weren't as many people Fox News
wasn't there Charlie Kirk's Turning
Point USA wasn't there so the sort of
college Republican sect wasn't there it
felt a little bit empty quite frankly
and not as energetic Andrew do you think
uh we may be in danger of missing uh
desantis's appeal because uh even though
you know at CPAC among conservative
actress he doesn't have that that trumpy
uh Pizzazz uh he has still got according
to polls about 30 percent of the
Republican vote and he hasn't even
officially started running yet I think
Nate Cohn at the New York Times uh has
calculated that he's doing better in
early polls than Reagan John McCain
Barack Obama or Joe Biden were at a
similar stage
um when you look at the broader
Republican electorate uh does he have
more of a hold on them
well he'll certainly get a Big Slice of
them I mean but the you know we're
talking about
you know who will get the biggest slice
I I still firmly believe it'll be Trump
especially when DeSantis you know has to
cope with you know the the Nikki Haley's
of this world or
whoever else jumps in I mean it's not
clear if there's going to be many of
them but when a sort of crowded field
um I think it would be better for Trump
if it's not a crowded field actually if
it's just him versus DeSantis if you
imagine a debate stage with just the two
of them then Trump can on unleash his
full
um rhetorical vehemence
um on the santis if there's a whole
bunch of them there they're all sort of
nibbling at trump it might it might go
the other way I I mean I still I mean I
I've I can't somehow I can't see
DeSantis really eating into the mega
vote
um too much I mean he'll get some of
them and he'll certainly get all those
you know or get a lot of those Suburban
College Republicans or whatever who
uh who like trumpism without Trump which
is what you know in a lot of ways we get
with DeSantis and I think they they may
well detect you know there's a very so
slithery
aspect of DeSantis which I think sort of
comes through
um so you know we're talking about who
gets the nomination in the end my money
is still on Trump and of course you know
the Democrats are hoping fervently it's
Trump
um and they don't like the endure of
DeSantis at all
um you know Trump as a you know as I as
I as I wrote he he's going to very much
run on the sort of nationalist
anti-war you know he would have settled
the Ukraine war within hours he will
settle over the Ukraine war within ours
and DeSantis has edged towards that he's
signed on to the no black no blank check
for Ukraine uh so stream which is sort
of the halfway house for Republicans
um but um you know DeSantis he'll run
you know he's got anti-woke he you know
his big thing was sort of anti-vaxxer
and you know I'm the one who kept
Florida open
um you know I defied pouchy and all that
um you know actually he didn't for quite
a while wasn't until he realized and
this is you know he is very clever he he
he he sensed that the Maga crowd didn't
you know were recoiled from the mandates
recoiled from the mandatory vaccines
were recoiled from lockdowns and masks
and all that but you know by
I think even now and certainly by next
year I think all the sort of memories of
that will have faded so it won't be
quite a as potent as selling point as he
might have hoped Daniel Ukraine is
already emerging as a major talking
point uh in the Republican primary
um do you think that Donald Trump's kind
of Peace suit piece through strength
message that he he would be able to
solve it in a day by just talking to
Vladimir Putin do you think that has cut
through to use the slightly disgusting
phrase
possibly I think that Trump has always
tried to appeal to an imagined Middle
America so he visited uh East Palestine
in Ohio if you recall where the train
derailment occurred and so there's this
sort of blue-collar cultural uh culture
that he tries to appeal to and you have
to remember and as Steve Bannon points
out on his podcast war room all the time
that's where the boys who go to fight
the wars are from and so Trump is trying
to appeal to that crowd like we don't
want another Iraq and Afghanistan
situation we don't want another George
Bush situation we want to get out of it
so he really tries to position himself
as an outsider on that issue and what he
said at his speech in CPAC was I didn't
get us involved in more Wars I got us
out of them and so that's his commitment
that he's tried to make and position
help himself differently from people
like DeSantis who has already received
like a passive endorsement from Jeb Bush
on Fox so I think that that's something
that we really have to look out for it's
hugely critical and Americans generally
speaking after having been in some ways
red pilled by those Wars on terrorism
they don't want it anymore they don't
want another mass mass War
let's go back to DeSantis and Vibes
Danielle I think
is it possible I did a piece on it this
week and I was thinking about this is it
possible that the scientists can create
his own Vibe because he is uh Andrew
compared him to Nixon he is uh he does
have this professional very serious uh
atmosphere about him he does campaign
quite belligerently against woke which
is obviously a quite an emotive issue
um do you think he can create his own
Vibe which is uh different enough to
trumpism to inspire some optimism
so I think that DeSantis really relies
on this uh culture War division which is
honestly a classic tactic of the
Republican party it's a sort of
diversion away from maybe more systemic
change around military interventionism
or trade or tax which Trump uh tried to
take on and that was his appeal so
DeSantis I think it I I think it was one
of you who said he sort of cringe
sometimes and DeSantis will have to kind
of own his cringe if he's going to have
something vibey or authentic so on the
one hand he can be pretty belligerent
with the Press but that's something he
almost learned from Trump and so is he
going to be able to find his own
authenticity in his wankish nerdiness as
opposed to trying to copy what is
essentially just a a an opposition to
the Press which became popularized in
Trump but honestly has its roots in
generations and Decades of conservatism
and alternative media in conservatism so
we'll see if he can make his own
authentic cringe
Andrew finally
um DeSantis is uh economically
conservative economically right-wing if
you like
um and uh Trump is not and uh this week
he's been hitting DeSantis pretty hard
on the point that he will protect uh
Social Security and Medicare
um Sanchez came out very quickly and
said so would he
um but his voting record suggests
otherwise and that uh means that Trump
is on the side of a Republican party
that is increasingly working class
increasingly left-wing it seems in its
uh economic ideas uh do you think that's
the sensitive biggest problems he's not
really left-wing enough for the new
Republican Party
well that's an attractive thought
um you know I just want to say something
about the sentence you know they've got
this huge 20-point Victory and uh in the
election
um
in 22 but he you know he was up
it would have been hard for him to lose
I mean because there were Democrats put
up this pathetic character Jolly Crist
the Democratic party in Florida is
essentially sort of Fallen apart the
national and Democrats had given up on
that didn't give them any money
um the Santa's had finally come around
to this popular sort of anti-lockdown
position which was very popular in in
Florida so although you know he carries
the aura of sort of triumphant success
with him
um I'm not so sure that's going to sort
of
you know that that he's really that
brilliant and successful a politician
um you know he didn't he scraped home uh
in his first election
um with the help of trump which Trump
will certainly not let him forget
um he you know I think I think once
we're into the Republican primaries
um
I think this sort of populist of you
know his attempt to be a populist well
Paul pretty plaid especially one if
Trump starts chanting the names of all
the sort of millionaires who've given
him money and you know and actually
Trump might have a have a go Trump trump
the Communists might have a go at sort
of talking about the incredible favors
DeSantis has done for insurance
companies for you know landlord
companies for all the rest in in Florida
so um I think it could be it will
certainly be a fun race I'm looking
forward to it
I think it will be fun uh Daniel I
finally I actually like to ask you one
more question and I'm sorry if this is
sexist because I'm asking because you're
a woman but there's been a lot of talk
about Casey uh DeSantis uh Rhonda Santos
wife uh and that she is apparently the
the sort of driving force the brains
behind the operation uh and has actually
pushed Ron DeSantis into running uh
because he's actually a bit reluctant do
you have a sense of her and whether she
might have her own vibes
well I know that uh the first lady of
Florida definitely has a style that is
very distinct I haven't seen someone
wear Opera gloves to a speech in a very
long time she definitely has a kind of
Jackie O energy which you know if you
spend any time in CPAC or among certain
sects of conservatism there is a sort of
uh you know uh performative femininity
that happens in a way uh it definitely
is fun to dress up for CPAC I'll say
that
um but I would say that she definitely
has ambition she's a former television
personality herself and so that would
definitely help him in trying to seem
more authentic or speaking to the kind
of local television news tabloid style
that Americans are really familiar with
that they wake up to every day on local
news so possibly you know her presence
and her energy and her ability to
connect to that to audiences and I mean
that by television audiences might
actually help uh Ron in the long run
it's certainly going to be very
interesting Danielle and Andrew thank
you very much indeed for joining us
now let's turn to Westminster uh suela
bravman the Home Secretary has been in
the news this week following the
publication of her illegal migration
bill there's also been a leak of an
email in which she referred to the
activist blob including civil servants
who have been trying to block the
government from addressing these small
boats crisis I'm joined by Katie Bulls
our indefatigable political editor
uh and Katie let's start with this bill
and the reaction to it and the leak of
this email is in a lot of trouble
I'm not sure if she is I mean I think on
the civil servant Point
um so there was a row about an email
which went out through the conservative
party
um which claimed to be from Sue out of
Braverman I think anyone who read it
would have assumed that given it was
signed by her
um and it laid some of the blame for the
lack of progress on small boats over the
years at the door of civil servants now
lots of Tori MPS will say this publicly
ministers may say it privately but for
the Home Secretary to say that um that
led to several complaints as a breach of
her role as Home Secretary but she has
since said she did not sanctioned that
email so the rare has now moved to
um if there is the case and I think
number 10 are not disputing that line of
events and you know how did that come to
be and it is a problem but it's a
problem which I think she has some
defense for
um and then I think more generally
um you have a situation where lots of
people are criticizing the Home
Secretary this week but the question and
I think one we won't really know for a
few months is are the people criticizing
the tourism people that the Tories want
to criticize them yes in terms of Labor
Refugee Charities
legal figures so it becomes a wedge
issue and because right now I think Tori
MP is a pretty United around the bill
that's been proposed
um the real problem I think is is
actually workable because you get a
short-term hit in terms of Tory MP
saying yes the government's sounding
tough Senator bereavement is sounding
tough on this
um but for some of the reasons you just
outlined those questions about how much
change is this really going to make and
if the Tory party can't stand the
problem then they're in a lot of trouble
and let's talk about Europe because a
few of the people today are talking
about Europe is signaling its discomfort
with this bill and it's a very big
change in mood music between the
government and Brussels because last
week of course we had Northern Ireland
protocol and so on and there was this
strange Harmony seemed to be breaking
out between uh Rishi sunak and Ursula
vandalone and yet today we're reading
the European Union saying that it risks
peace over the brexit deal even bringing
in the possibility that it might affect
uh Ukraine and and sort of Europe's
efforts to repel Vladimir Putin which
sounds a bit far-fetched to me
um what's going on there
so I think what we've seen with this
bill is the government is pushing it to
the limits of what is legally
um okay with the current agreements we
have and I think from the letter you
mentioned which wrote to MPS saying
there's an over 50 chance this will not
meet the standards or breach the echr
now I've spoken to figures in government
who were quite surprised that Savannah
Reuben used that phrase you know over 50
in her letter to MPS and they wonder if
that was uh more a political move and
because we also was saying on this
specifically she's admitting
um that you know the bill could struggle
well in the in the world that we are
currently in to lots of Tory MPS they
like the idea that this could reach the
echr so it's so some things she is
showing some leg to the right of the
Party by saying we've gone so tough I've
pushed things so far it might not pass
the test when uh in government I think
that they are more hopeful about um how
this will go I think on the ee reaction
so far the European commission figures
that have been quite critical I think
what would be really interesting to see
is where our EU leaders on this because
when it comes to for example the first
French UK conference in some time where
um Richardson is trying to charm
Emmanuel macron and I think it deals
with France as seen as uh almost as
important
um as this bill in terms of
um stemming the flow of small boats in
the short term at least and do they
manage to have I mean I hate to use the
word but some people are saying Bromance
and make some progress there or do you
figure such as Emmanuel macron start to
criticize the policy
um in number 10 I think the hope is that
actually they had you've had the foreign
secretary doing quite a lot of laying
the groundwork with EU leaders and
therefore you could have a situation
where you know these problems are once
being faced by lots of the countries
within the EU so there could be more
patients for how far the UK is trying to
go so we got to we're back in the brexit
phase to see is the European commission
speaking for member states or actually
are we going to see a little bit of a
difference
um in terms of what we hear from both
give us a bit of Intelligence on on the
Bromance between Rishi sunak and
Emmanuel macron I mean they do seem like
quite similar figures in some ways uh
they're both quite small for one thing
uh they also have they're financially
literate they have experience in matters
of Finance
um and they seem to get on we'll we'll
see today and certainly given how bad
things got with this trust as prime
minister between France and and Britain
uh there's a lot of Hope among uh people
who want Britain for us to get along but
uh they will get along well yeah I mean
I think given the rocky relations
between the UK and France um under Boris
Johnson and Liz truss and yes Boris
Johnson and Manny macron they were once
described having a bromance and but it
never seemed to lead to much because of
some of the you know the difference in
approaches on issues and I think it's
Richie student doesn't need to do much
to look as though his Bromance is better
than Boris Johnson macrames was yeah
yeah and and I think the fact that you
have the protocol deal is actually
really significant in terms of improving
relations between the UK and France and
part of the reason Richardson got there
and you had the um press conference
where uh the Wonderland was talking
about dear Rishi which I think sums up
everything about why how I think lots of
figures in the EU think that Richie's
doing something they're much more able
to do business with and I think one of
the problems Boris Johnson always have
is because he had signed the original
brexit deal to then try and seek changes
to it or say you know this is a mistake
man it was really hard for you to then
trust him so they've now decided that
they trust Rishi sunak I think the fact
that the protocol deal has landed pretty
well on the UK side yes we may get some
rebellions but the fact that we still
haven't heard from the ERG all the dup I
think at the very least that means that
this is not turning into a fiery
Showdown and and I think that is adding
to confidence that this is a leader they
can work with
um and Richard Cena does want to do
things differently in terms of
diplomatic relations I think it's been
quite a point of thinking by being being
polite
working hard privately he thinks you can
get more than sometimes playing more to
the gallery and so I think I think we'll
see that
um when they when they meet and as you
say quite similar in some ways though I
think Emmanuel macron is perhaps uh one
who uh is still quite a performer in
public he is he is and in fact there's
never been I don't think there's been
any significant male Western leader with
which he hasn't had some sort of romance
yeah he gets about he does so the
question is you know can can they take
to the next level can they take it to
the next level good question Katie uh
great to have an update as always
let's look North to Sweden I think it's
well established by now that Sweden is
not the liberal Paradise that a lot of
people thought it was however the extent
of Swedish crime and Swedish gang
culture is less well-known in the
magazine this week Paulina nerding
writes a very interesting piece about
the way in which Swedish gangs are
slowly taking over in some cities
including taking over local politics I'm
joined now by the crime reporter and
author Ann Turnquist
and can you give us a lay of the land
how bad is crime in Sweden now
when it comes to shootings uh we're
talking about 40 shootings every year
just in Stockholm which is Sweden's
biggest town and 40 might not sound like
a lot but we're a small country so you
have to kind of multiply it by 10 to get
a kind of a UK um comparison
this has gotten worse and worse in the
past 10 years when I started working
when I wrote my first book it was a
merger that was that shocked everyone
because you know people are killing each
other with kalashnikovs and
um but it's I just had this feeling back
then that this might just be like a
little you know Prelude and
unfortunately that's exactly what's
happened and people don't even react
anymore when there's another shooting in
the newspapers so it's bad and
um
and the politicians are
trying to fix it
um but
some of the reforms have just been a bit
short-sighted
why is it you think that Sweden is
failing so singularly I mean other
countries Germany for instance has
high levels of similar types of
immigration uh similar problems with
islamist groups what is it about Sweden
that they're failing so badly on it
I mean it's a really important question
I would like to know that this the
Gangland has nothing to religion
whatsoever uh but it is of course the
senators are in these um suburbs where a
lot of the young men have a parent or a
grandparent from another country
the main reason and you know police
officers say this politicians say this
social workers say this parents say this
is that the Swedish school system is
failing young men or boys their grades
are it's like the rest of the western
world I mean the the girls are doing
better in school
and if you don't do well in school like
you don't have a lot of career options
um there's also a recent book
um
a lawyer had spoken to some of our
younger clients
and they just feel completely apart from
Swedish Society I mean they don't even
have like a concept of what you could
maybe work with I mean you like you
obviously know you can work in a
restaurant but in terms of like they're
actually being career options apart from
like I mean you can be a footballer you
could be a rapper or work in your
uncle's restaurant
um and it's incredibly limiting as for
the parts why we're shooting each other
so much
people can't really figure out why
that's so unique for Sweden I wouldn't
say that the rest of Europe doesn't have
the same kind of problems I mean with
the drugs
the thing that we are really struggling
to understand is like why are we the
ones who are shooting each other so much
like what what is it that's special
about a swedes to go like crazy
and one of my theories because there's
really no like consensus about the
reason is that it just has ended up in a
situation where you where you don't
bring a knife to gunfights so a few
people get guns and then all of a sudden
you know that your rival has a gun so
you get your own gun
and almost all the guns are from the
former Yugoslavia leftovers from the war
it's it's not difficult to get them here
and and we are also just lately seeing
what they've seen in um
I mean they saw this in La a few years
ago I mean you can print you can 3D
print weapons so
you know get I mean we I don't think
there's any way to get rid of the
weapons we have to get rid of the
reasons why people are shooting each
other
and forgive me if I'm indulging in in
cliches here but is it something to do
with the soft liberalism of Sweden in
that there isn't really a Law and Order
culture in Sweden because for a long
time there's never really needed to be
foreign
I mean I certainly have intrude people
over the years his parents have moved
here from other countries who call
called the legal system soft one really
important thing which is the theme of my
second book where witness was actually
murdered
um in the middle of the day because he
was helping the police
um is that
basically like why should I testify why
should I move and have to like pull my
kids out of school why do I have to live
with death threats
um if a the gag storm testify against
might not go to prison and if he does
he'll be out
I don't know like in seven years
I mean what's most I mean basically you
commit a really bad crime in Sweden and
you
a lot of people get 12 years in prison
so you're out up to two-thirds of your
sentence you get 18 or you can get live
but even if you get life you have the
possibility of applying for parole after
20 years so
so I think that is like people just are
too scared and it's not worth it to
testify against them
as Paulina says in her piece though
where the authorities don't have control
gangsters will start to take control and
in fact in the city of uh forgive me if
I'm pronouncing it wrong
the gangsters are actually getting
involved in politics can you tell us a
little bit about that
like what looks to the beginning like
just kind of like infighting in uh the
Social Democrat Party locally
and uh the local leader was deposed but
it was this like membership meeting
where a vote was taken against her and
all of a sudden like 50 new members
showed up and
um and they could be tied to different
um organized crime groups after the
journalists looked at it a little bit
closer
so the suspicion is that like they
didn't like this politician for for
various reasons and they just recruited
all their like crooked friends and you
know basically made sure that she had to
leave her post
this is under investigation and I also
just spontaneously felt when I read
Pauline annoying's article that was
factually correct I think we also have
to remember that Sweden small Stockholm
smaller the suburbs of Stockholm like
both sugar are even smaller so like
who's related with whom and who's
friends with who and who went to school
with whomever like it's it's very like
how do you draw a line between who is
like a criminal slash connected
criminals Etc I don't doubt that this
needs to look at be look at looked into
properly which is being done I hope
um but the dividing like this very fine
line nowadays between like who's up to
no good and who's Maybe
should be speaking up a bit more when
people are up to no good and that's a
very big answer I know but it's just not
at all I mean that is the real shocking
thing for the smallness of Sweden
the bigness uh of its crime problem
yeah I know and it's huge
um one thing that I think several people
have pointed out is that actually
this town just south of Stockholm called
saratel yeah why worked uh for a long
time
they were the ones who kind of had this
crime first so 10 years ago God sorry
it's like a little it's 12 years ago now
time flies uh and they had a problem
with like infiltration in City Hall and
um
and they really tried to get at it and
and also people just I mean there's a
lot people were defrauding the social
welfare system uh there's a huge
investigation at the time into like
welfare fraud
um I moved one of Sweden's biggest
police investigations ever and they did
nail a few people and one of them
um was related to a very well-known
politician so that kind of illustrates
as well it's like okay so his sister's a
but does that necessarily mean
he is like what's his role I mean it
just becomes a bit
yes yeah you mentioned that uh and the
reaction in Sweden has sometimes turned
towards a sort of uh blame immigrants uh
mentality has there also been uh the
opposite problem in a way of
um authorities or people involved with
these crimes don't want to be racist and
so therefore they're not talking openly
about what's going on
people say that and I do know that quite
an outspoken public servant in the north
west of Stockholm did like lose his job
under mysterious circumstances
um but he wasn't so much talking about
he wasn't talking about immigration he
was just like look at this stuff like
look we need to fix
ABCD and um
and
it's almost like I mean it's really bad
at taking criticism like we're so proud
we're so proud that the world knows us
it's like we're so logical and we're so
liberal and like oh we got it right
um so there's like this huge thing where
you're just like oh
he's criticizing me like we can't take
it like it's just like some kind of
collective psychosis
um so in sotelia the social Democrats
and other politicians have told me we
have been telling our national
counterparts a national level about
these problems for like 15 years and
they do perceive that 15 years ago
like the general consensus was that oh
we don't need to talk about that whereas
they were like listen like our town is
is about to blow up and it did blow up
you mentioned that uh a lot of Voters
are very concerned about crime that it's
the top concern uh among voters is there
a is there a are there politicians who
are actually proposing actions or taking
actions that are making a difference and
not just talking
I mean the Social Democrat government
which was in power until last elections
did have this like
it was like a long list we were forums
we were going to put through and a lot
of them were quite reasonable
um so they were working through that for
example they made
um they introduced tougher sentence
sentencing for aggravated guns
possession or illegal arms possession
um
and the new government which is
conservative and relies on the support
of the Sweden Democrats in Parliament
they produce these enormous documents it
was just like this is what we're going
to do in Sweden
and I had I held a little seminar the
other day where I was I was going
through the list of all their Law and
Order
um proposals but I was doing it in a
very like I read it and like commented
on it spontaneously as I was going like
oh great yeah wonderful not gonna work
but also some of them like um
and one of the things this new document
says is like we have to invest heavily
in Social Services but then tons of
parties have said that forever and I
don't know if those Investments are
working
there are some things so this is really
boring this is technical level but we
have really strict privacy laws which
means that there are actual legal
obstacles for the school the police
Social Services
um and other kind of official agencies
and Social Services functions to share
information about young people which
means that sometimes people just fall
through the cracks there's no
coordination and sometimes I've been
really working they're called like
social
um I can't translate this well
like it's it's kind of funny because in
subscript means like you go in and do
something but it also means SWAT team so
it's like a social SWAT team
but it's actually people like working
together to help young people
and how I've read a few pieces about it
but it's difficult for someone like me
to understand how uh widespread and
popular is Gangster culture gangster rap
among Swedish youth
super popular
um
that has been for about 10 years and
and the police aren't happy about it one
of the police officers compared it to
like people listening to like white
power music you know like what's the
difference you're glorifying killing I
think there's a huge amount of
differences in between them but you know
not being a music reporter I'm gonna
leave that to the music quarters but
it's huge yeah it's definitely not
something uh Brits associated with
Sweden and we'll leave it there but
thank you very much for joining us
next up cycling versus pedestrians
there's been a lot of interest in
Britain this week over the sad story of
a woman cyclist who died after an
altercation with Oriole gray a
pedestrian oil gray has been charged
with manslaughter
but should Oriole gray really be going
to prison I'm joined by Mary dejeski who
is a spectator contributor as well as
another Mary Mary Wakefield who is our
commissioning editor
Mary dejevski I'll start with you
um your piece which was under the
headline cyclists have been given a
license to ride on the pavement uh went
down a storm on The Spectator website it
attracted lots of interest and judging
from the comments and so on this there
is a lot of concern out there obviously
especially among motorists and
pedestrians
that cyclists are being given uh the
right to ride on the pavement and that
the treatment of oriole gray is
disgraceful could you just outline for
any viewers that haven't been following
it what's happened to Oriole gray and
the details of that particular case
well what appears to have happened is
that she was walking along and it has to
be said she is a 46 year old woman
um who is partially sighted and has
various other disabilities and she was
walking along the pavement and she felt
the disciplist
um was coming rather close to her
cycling on the pavement
and what is said is that and was given
in evidence is that she shouted swore at
the cyclist to get on the road and get
off the pavement and then she put her
hand out and there is also a question of
whether she actually hit her but the
consequence was catastrophic and tragic
which was that the cyclist
um was pushed or fell off her bike into
the path of a vehicle that could not
stop and she was killed and that is the
source of the manslaughter charge that
the cyclist faced and she was convicted
of manslaughter she was sentenced to
three years in prison
and I think her lawyer says that she is
going to appeal but as yet there's no
news on that it's also I have to say
that I'm not clear whether she's been
given bail or whether she's been sent
straight to prison my impression is that
she's been sent to prison and I mean
I've seen the video and it's it's pretty
horrifying because of what happens but
uh it's not clear whether she pushes her
or not but if if Oriole gray did push
her and of course everybody feels sorry
for her in many ways because that was
obviously not her intention to uh to
kill this cyclist uh if she did push her
though that is uh a direct cause of the
death of the cyclist so there is a case
to be made
um that it is manslaughter if she should
push her is it is there not
yes I mean there there's the same case
that might be made
um against a cyclist or indeed a driver
um who knocks over somebody
um if he's
um speeding
um or um there was a case of a cyclist
who killed a pedestrian on a Crossing I
think
um and he was sentenced to 18 months in
prison only 18 months even though his
bike was defective and he cut through a
red light and he had no breaks
um it seems to me that there's a large
um there's a complete disproportion here
yes
um Mary number two uh uh Mary says in
her piece you know which of us has not
at some point wanted to shout it out or
wanted to shout out or even push a
cyclist because cyclists are often quite
obnoxious on the roads uh they drive
people crazy
um do you share that feeling I do I mean
I hate cyclists for the most part
um I think in this case
um the worry is the disproportionate
rate like you can hate a cyclist and
sort of swear at them and a lot of us
behave very badly but I do think there's
a problem with the disproportionate rage
people feel towards cyclists and I do
think it endangers them in some cases
because we're going fast you know I've
had people try and stick
um quite rightly in some ways you know a
walking stick through my front wheel
because they're enraged this is
particularly kind of going through
Kenston Gardens on a yeah I'm a
self-hating scientist but I mostly hate
a different sort of cyclist but that's
that's getting a little esoteric the
difference between cyclists it's the
commuting cyclists you know going down
going super fast who are unbelievably
rude who are the worst Lottery thing but
um so some of the things you can do to a
cyclist when you're feeling a bit cross
actually is incredibly dangerous for
them in this case you know a spasm of
Rage involves the death of someone so
one of the lessons here is I think don't
be so disproportionately Furious that
you forget what your actions can can do
to someone going fast on a bike Mary
Mary dejeski I think that's right is it
not that um cyclists are scared because
uh a lot of the time they're driving
pretty fast through uh quite dangerous
roads and the reason they behave in the
way that they do and it's a way of
Behaving that annoys a lot of people is
because they're frightened a lot of the
time and when people are scared they
tend to act aggressively
well I think that's partly true but I
think if
London and it has to be
it happened in Huntington
might be seen sort of philosophically as
maybe closer to a cycling City such as
Cambridge
um than to London but if we look at
London
um then I would say London has spent
exorbitant amounts of money trying to
separate cyclists um from pedestrians
and cyclists from traffic the recycle
Lanes all over London that have backed
up the traffic that have extended
people's Journeys if they're in cars or
buses
um incredibly it now takes me twice as
long to get from my flat to another part
of Central London than it did before the
introduction of cycle lens huge amounts
of money and if you look at these cycle
these cycling Lanes at many times of day
and there's hardly anybody in them all
the cyclists are in are in the the bus
lanes or the car lanes because they find
it quicker but the car lines and the bus
lines they're now confined to 20 miles
an hour and what happens is that
commuting cyclists are actually going
faster than 20 miles an hour but Mary
that's not our fault you know direct
your rage at siddique as a
cyclists
we didn't ask for these cycle names all
of us this is there's a lot of local
government a war on the car going on and
I blame Boris frankly but you know
that's another thing
um and but it's not the fault of
individual cyclists so I feel like we
received the built-up Rage of the
frustrated motorists who should be angry
at government both local and big
government for its war on on cars
and that's not our fault I didn't want a
ridiculous cycle laying down the
Melbourne road which frustrates me more
than anyone else you know we're we're
we're we're sort of channeled past bus
stops where it's very hard not to hit
anyone because the cycle Lane goes
straight past the you know place we it's
I don't think it's our fault
well I think it's your fault for not
using the lanes that you've been with
why should I have to use them if they're
there for riding on the pavement I don't
think there's any excuse for writing on
the page but I completely agree with
that but but do you think perhaps the
reaction is disproportionate I mean
obviously in this case it was and the
whole thing's really unfortunate well I
think that I think that it's possible to
say that the reaction can be
disproportionate because everything has
now been piled on pedestrians it's not
just the cyclists we've got e-scooters
we've got e-bikes we've got skateboards
and everybody's really taking it as open
season for the pain but that I think
yeah that's the only place where
pedestrians can walk but that affects us
too you should I mean that you should
see the trouble cyclists have with
e-bikes on the bike lane you know
they're going at 30 miles an hour where
I have every sympathy with that but I do
draw the line at cyclists on the papers
because I think that's that that is
really the that's where there is
competition and the only place where
pedestrians are can I'd have to have a
right to feel yeah I think that's
totally well maybe a little a little
finger wag rather than an actual shove
would be more proportionate
um a little finger finger wag and
a
use of language shall we say let's
compromise on use of language
as I said it might be swearing is really
my register
I understand people who
I don't I don't want to interject
between two disagreeing areas but I I do
I do wonder if uh the headline of your
piece is is true uh you know have uh
cyclists do cyclists now have the
license to ride on the boat does does
this ruling mean that
well I think it's fair to extrapolate
from the ruling that it does recognize
um the right of a cyclist to to ride on
the pavement which wasn't there before
because my understanding is that the
default position before was that in most
places it's illegal for cyclists to to
ride on the pavement even though that
isn't generally enforced
um but there seems to be a slight gray
area in this case because the Council of
of uh of all people seem to seem to be
confused as to whether this particular
part of the pavement was theoretically
something called a shared space where
cyclists could ride on the pavement and
where pedestrians were expected to share
nicely
um it didn't look when you see the
pictures and you see the CCTV it didn't
look to me very much like a shared space
but um that gray area I suspect is going
to loom rather large if there's an
appeal isn't that the problem then uh
Mary W that uh that this particular part
of road was not very clear what it was
this case is is an odd one isn't it
altogether because
um you know what was her name Oriole
gray is is reacts oddly she's not just
waving at her she actually as I've seen
it looking at the footage deliberately
blocks the cyclist the cyclist had she
not been 77 herself and a bit bewildered
would have gone right to the wall side
but she didn't she allowed herself to be
uttered into the road where there was a
driver who I don't think was paying
attention so but I also think that um
the whole publicity surrounding the case
is less likely to make me ride on
Pavements I'm now more scared I'm not
incentivized I'm never going on a
pavement again it's a very interesting
and unusual case in the in in in this it
also in in the aspect that the two
cyclists were women of a certain age
um and normally when you have these
these pavement conflicts you've got
young men in lycro dashing to get
somewhere or trying to deliver something
um and you've got
um say
um an elderly woman or somebody
partially decided trying to navigate all
the obstacles otherwise on the pavement
that's the usual conflict of interest on
Pavements this was slightly different
Mary and Mary I think we will have to
leave it there thank you both very much
for coming on to spectator TV
lastly strap in tight because we're
about to start talking about corsets
there has been a row in the media
largely over some Bridgeton actresses
two Bridgeton actresses who have
complained about corsets being far too
uncomfortable which then LED uh to
reports that Netflix and perhaps the BBC
were going to ban them as items of
clothing
with me now is the art and culture
critic Francesca peacock who's also a
spectator contributor
Francesca corsets uh Netflix have said
that they're not going to ban courses
and of course they will never go to bank
courses were they because corset dramas
bodice-ripping dramas uh are an absolute
staple of the entertainment industry uh
and there was never any realistic chance
that they were going to be I think
The Source came from
an unnamed source
his son and said that off the back of a
number of complaints from a couple of
actresses on one of their very big shows
Bridgeton they were going to contemplate
Banning corsets and letting actresses
wear their in underwear which is quite
an interesting idea like
um and
um they also said that the BBC might
follow suits and then Netflix
um replied very quickly saying that
wasn't in their plans at all and they
weren't ever going to Van corsets and
but it has come after quite a few
complaints which is interesting yeah
it's a fundamental threat to their
business
you laugh of course but in your piece a
very good piece in The Spectator this
week you say
um that uh corsets were not necessarily
as uncomfortable as people think the
idea that they are so uncomfortable
comes from because we've managed to
conflate the idea of tight lacing which
is where a woman would be pulled very
tightly into a corset to create the
illusion of a tiny waist we've conflated
that with the idea of a corset or stays
or jumps which was just another form of
undergarment quite akin to wearing a bra
but they were the ones that were tightly
pulled in where I mean I've done my
research they uh deformed rib cages and
things like that there's some degree of
truth about that there's also quite uh
so everything we know about that in
large part comes from this like the
corset controversy and it was part of
like a women's health craze thing our
women too delicate too tight lacing
should they not be doing this so it's
quite hard often to distinguish like
fact from fiction and what was just
massively hyped up um but certainly yes
in some cases tight lacing was very
dangerous and there are like very famous
stories of women who managed to get
there
um waistlines down to like a 16
circumference which is Tiny if you think
about it and that's what uh Vicky Crips
was complaining about she had to go into
the 16-inch yes for the purposes of her
films yes which obviously if you're
going to be a film called can't really
not wear a corset but so that is a film
about the empress Elizabeth of Austria
and she's very famous for being
um like probably diagnosed with anorexia
today she barely ate a thing she'd eat
like
um just clear beef broth and she
exercised every day she had a gymnasium
put into every single one of her palaces
she'd go on for long walks endlessly
dragging her servants behind her in the
rain in the cold and she very famously
had um a 16 inch circumference waist and
she would wear a different type of
corset actually to what was fashionable
in court at the time hers was um leather
all over rather than just bones in
different places and it would be pulled
so tightly by so many people that she
would have a 16 inch waist and uh it's
interesting is it not that the uh the
obsession with a very very slim slim
waist has been is centuries old busts
and bottoms can do what they want to a
certain extent over the years but uh
wastes have always been an obsession
definitely so the corset goes hand in
hand and so initially if you take the
lesbian period for example you'd have
stays which would create like an upside
down triangle effect and then dresses
were incredibly wide so wide that women
can walk through rooms or they took up
more space at court
um so definitely a slim waist has been
an obsession for a very long time but I
think it's quite important to note that
um it's not necessarily just a female
ideal as well so the same Elizabeth
period men were wearing things to
um tighten in their waists especially as
well in the 18th century like the
Dandy's late 18th century early 19th
century Beau brummel there was a corset
named after him for men yeah I'm
breathing in because I haven't I haven't
got mine corset on today uh you also say
that it's similar to Spanx which is the
Kim Kardashian just explained for the
viewers who don't know what Spanx are so
very um tight underwear that looks far
smaller than the body that it's about to
be put on and it's crazy at the moment
to wear shapewear and I think it
probably always has been actually in
many different ways this is a different
manifestation of it um but I just think
it's quite interesting to see that maybe
the Bridgeton line of corsetry perhaps
has more in common with Spanx than it
does with actual 18th century corsetry
because
um well early 19th century so Bridgeton
set in the Regency period
um which was one moment in British and
French history where corsets weren't
actually necessarily All the Rage women
could wear either a much shorter version
of a corset which didn't constrict their
waste or nothing at all they would draw
attention to their nakedness by um going
out to very thin dresses and like
splattering their dresses with water
um but so this is one period where
because of the Empire like waistline um
you didn't necessarily have to wear a
corset but in the Bridgeton they all are
so they're perhaps historically and
accurately like um pursuing this idea of
a very small waistline and Spanx there's
no suggestions that the Spanx are bad
for you or I don't think so Kim
Kardashian did go through waist training
though to wear a corset which is quite
an interesting idea yeah interesting but
it's waist training so it's where you um
wear progressively tighter corsets to
try and make your waist as Tiny as
possible okay so I think there is a
suggestion that that is bad for you yes
Francesca has been very enlightening
thank you very much indeed thank you
that's it for spectator TV this week I
hope you enjoyed the show if you did
don't forget to subscribe to our YouTube
channel you do that by clicking the
Subscribe button at the bottom of the
screen and also of course the Bell icon
at the top of the screen to make sure
you don't ever miss an episode
thank you very much for watching see you
next time
[Music]